hey happy monday people i'm dave rubin
this is the reuben report direct message
on march 14 20
22 we're live streaming on rumble
youtube and blaze tv do me a favor and
subscribe tap the notification bell
that's somewhere on your screen over
there and uh then you've done your part
to make sure that what i do here is seen
by people uh speaking of being seen and
perhaps read or listened to by people
doper in this country is coming out next
month
uh april 12th to be precise but you can
pre-order right now at daverubin.com
book here's a little preview of the
cover that's a digital version here's a
real book and then that reminded us this
morning when michael busted this thing
out it reminded me that we still have
this i meant to auction this off look at
this so this is don't burn this book
this is literally
the first copy of don't burn this book
and you may see that it's kind of chewed
through there and what happened was they
sent us some of you may remember this
they sent us a box the first box you
know like the first 20 books of don't
burn this book uh it's about two years
ago now when this thing came out and we
had just got clyde it was right at the
beginning of lockdown and he was a
rescue off the streets and he was still
wild he was crazy and he started chewing
through the box and he literally
chewed through the first copy and i said
i was going to auction it off and then
we just got very busy and it just never
happened so i still have this thing and
i would love to just give this to
somebody i think it's just a great uh
piece of memorabilia little piece of
history so just somebody i guess we'll
do it for the locals community it's like
make me an offer i can't refuse i don't
really want money just something like
trade me something for this thing it is
the first copy of don't burn this book
and uh don't burn this country is on the
way out i did the audiobook last week i
promise you guys you are going to dig it
and all this nonsense that is in the
world right now it is so related to what
i wrote in the book that i will probably
have to write another uh as for the big
show today uh you know some mornings we
wake up and it's just freaking
obvious what we're gonna do it's just
like man we know what we are doing today
we have got a perfect through line
through the show we're going to go
through uh some kamala harris stuff and
you know if you criticize her even
though she doesn't know what she's doing
and she's way over her head if you
criticize her you're racist that's
important to know immediately up top uh
and then bill maher
was on ben shapiro's sunday special
and it was super interesting like really
really interesting dare i promote
another channel on this year reuben
report but ben does a really nice job uh
you guys know how i feel about bill
maher i like bill maher i think he is a
sane liberal which is a very very small
sliver of what's left of the liberal
intelligencia um but he hasn't gotten to
the end of the road so we're going to go
through some clips on that and and then
we're going to talk about ron desantis
who is absolutely freaking fighting the
machine and doing it better and better
every single day
disney tried to smack him down he sat
down with the ceo of disney and he just
ain't taking any [ __ ] and guess what
disney you don't own us and you are not
our rulers and ron desantis knows that
so we got a big show for you today i'm
psyched i'm feeling good i'm caffeinated
and before i do any of that i want to
talk to you about american home shield
you know no one likes to think about
household breakdowns but they happen and
way more often than you'd like that's
why it pays to have a plan from american
home shield to help cover the costs to
repair and replace things like your
heating system ac or your fridge they
also know that no two homes are the same
that's why they have new options to help
you find just the right coverage
american home shield members get more
their plans help protect parts of up to
23 essential home system home systems
and appliances no matter how old they
are ahs also offers electronics coverage
available for an unlimited number of
eligible items like smart watches flat
screen tvs and more other options
include roof leak repair and pool and
spa coverage if american home shield
can't repair the covered item they'll
replace it they're helping me fix the
roof right now keep your home up and
running and budget on track with
american home shield right now reuben
report listeners can take 50 bucks off
their most comprehensive plan ever go to
ahs.com
reuben now to save 50 bucks that's
ahs.com
ruben for fifty dollars off any plan
american home shield be sure with the
shield services fees limitations and
exclusions apply c plan for details and
now back to me okay so let's talk about
the vice president of the united states
you might know this woman kamala harris
she was polling at zero not one not two
nor three she was polling at zero when
she was in the democratic primary and
then dropped out that's when we had that
whole big collection of half-wits
remember uh gay pete was in there and
elizabeth warren and a bunch of other
people that have all sort of gone to
irrelevance uh tulsi gabbard stayed in
for a long time and if the democrats had
selected her we might not be in this
mess that we're in right now but we'll
do more on that tomorrow
anyway kamal harris is deeply unpopular
she is not very bright and biden did
select her for diversity purposes in
that she is a black woman and also
purports to celebrate kwanzaa which of
course was a lie but she celebrated it
every year when she was child she has no
pictures of it but okay big kwon's a fan
too
anyway she's completely in over her head
on this thing when it comes to when i
say this thing i was about to say
ukraine and russia but everything
literally everything that this woman
does she has no idea what she's doing
she's a cackling maniac who is not doing
the proper research who is not being
briefed properly who isn't that bright
and well don't take my word for it
here's a little compilation of kamala if
i can ask you madam vice president
president biden has said that americans
will feel some pain for the sake of
defending freedom and liberty
but there does seem to be no end game in
sight
how long should americans expect how
long should we be bracing for
this really sort of
historic inflation and some
unprecedented gas prices
in terms of
the discussions that the president
johannes and i had they ranged in
subject including the issue of the black
sea and i'll let him
explain in more detail as he would like
but
we are again
fully aware and apprised because we are
in constant communication
with the president with his
administration here
about the concerns that they have about
the entire region and frankly the
vulnerability
all you have to do is look i wanted to
know if you think and if you asked the
united states to specifically accept
more refugees
okay
a friend in need is a friend indeed
so
i will say what i know we all say and i
will say over and over again the united
states stands firmly with the ukrainian
people in defense of the nato alliance
[Applause]
everything about her her constant jerky
emoji
there's something wrong with her there's
something look there's something wrong
with joe biden but there is something
seriously wrong with that woman we it's
like the biden thing we all know there's
something wrong with him but i think the
thing that we need to be focusing on
right now in this shell game game of
stupidity is what's wrong with this lady
okay
ukraine's not in nato let's put that
aside the other question she's talking
about the black sea what the hell are
you talking about we're asking about
inflation lady she is so over her head
she's not paying attention so now
if you were to criticize her it seems
like you could do it on merit right it's
just fairly obvious she uses a lot of
words but she's never really saying
anything she's confused she does the
awful laugh all the time when she
doesn't know what to say
but of course what this would lead us to
believe in 2022 is that if you criticize
her you're racist because that's exactly
what happened
on the
morning show called the view take a look
and i don't know that it's about her
laughing because i agree i think that
would be very inappropriate and that
that's something that they do to women i
think that she has gone on multiple
occasions a little bit underprepared
with with some of the questions that
she's been asked lester holt asked her a
pretty basic question that she couldn't
answer so i don't know if it's a staff
thing she's not prepared enough perhaps
she's not expecting the questions i
don't know what it is but i think that's
the issues this is like the fourth or
fifth time what it is is that they
constantly question the qualifications
of black women and that's why people are
saying that she's unprepared oh i
disagree i think you can disagree but
that's the truth of it and so this is
based in racism this is based in
misogyny and we're talking about a woman
that has extensive experience
abroad extensive experience as an
attorney expensive extensive experience
as
the chief legal officer of
one of our largest states in the country
and i i think this is just much ado
about nothing i mean we didn't talk
about vice president pence's uh the
right didn't talk about his handling of
the covet epidemic which i think or the
aids epidemic which i think led to you
know thousands and thousands of deaths
and what we what they're talking about
is is her laugh she was there
um as an emissary really and she wanted
to reassure the nato allies that uh that
as russia steps up its attacks on
ukraine that the united states was going
to be supportive in fact she's in i
think bulgaria right now she is prepared
she is seasoned
abroad she she gets wonderful marks
across the board but this is just
something that i think happens to women
and especially black women
all right sonny hostin we're gonna have
to talk about you for a moment and i
understand that you are a black woman
but that has nothing to do with why i'm
about to criticize you which in your
world means that i'm racist but in
reality no that's just not the truth and
until the rest of us stop playing this
stupid game i know you're going to keep
encroaching on us first off let me just
one comment that she said that made
literally no sense was that mike pence
uh his response having something to do
with the aids crisis the aids crisis was
basically in new york and san francisco
in the mid early to late 80s mike pence
was
vice president about
three years ago so i'm a little confused
he also is from indiana
i don't know what you mean by that um
but if you were to criticize his covid
policy
as vice president that would be just
fine and by the way plenty of people did
and it had nothing to do with them
criticizing him because he's a white man
or he's not a black woman or something
like that um the woman who spoke first
there who made uh i thought several
salient points with stephanie grisham i
think she's a guest host because they
can't find a decent conservative woman
who wants to sit on a panel with four
liberal maniacs and be yelled at and
dismissed the way sonny hostin just
dismissed stephanie stephanie's point
was not to overtly
and and sort of over the top criticize
kamala she said maybe she's
underprepared maybe her staff isn't
giving her the right information etc etc
like she actually was quite measured in
her criticism and then sonny just
admitted nope nope it's because she's a
black woman it's because she's a black
woman and it's like it has nothing to do
with that it has nothing to do with that
and i really really mean this we have to
stop playing this game because it is it
is dragging us into hell that is what
it's doing that if you legitimately
criticize someone if immediately
the other side is able to look at
whatever their intersectional
oppressions perceived oppressions are
and say no it's because they're black no
it's because they're gay no it's because
they're trans no it's because they're
muslim we got a major problem on our
hands because we will only be governed
by backwards idiots and maybe that's
exactly where we're at right now so
that's the perfect segue
to this interview that bill maher just
did with ben shapiro on the sunday
special so bill maher real quick i
always put the caveat up top when i talk
about bill maher
i like bill maher bill maher especially
when i was more say on the liberal side
of things or on the left side of things
was probably the biggest influence that
i had as a tv personality as a liberal
in terms of the ideas i cared about in
terms of who i agreed with he has
probably 20 hbo specials i'd say 15 of
them are phenomenal and probably five of
them are in the top 10 of hbo specials
of all time uh
but bill maher has not gotten to the end
of the road of where liberalism has led
and he's struggling with that i think
and when i've done these videos my hope
is that i can encourage him to see the
end of the road and i know his producers
watch this show
and uh supposedly i'm gonna be on bill
maher's podcast which is launching this
week i'm supposed to be on in the next
couple weeks or something i'd be happy
to have this conversation on his show
which apparently is going to be like a
two-hour long forum podcast or we can do
it
we can do it there we can do it here
whatever it is anyway
so bill maher went on
ben shapiro's show talking about what
has happened to the left what has
happened to the progressives and the
woke who have sort of destroyed
liberalism and i think most of you are
probably going to agree with everything
he said here but you'll see the
transition from what we just talked
about
um
but when you say woke you know it's
become
and i make fun of it too because it's
become an eye roll
in many ways if woke i assume at a
certain moment and it wasn't that long
ago before we didn't have the term i
only heard it i don't know what it was
three four years ago
five years ago at most when we heard the
term woke and it was like alert to
injustice okay i'm down with that i
always have been i hope people still
understand that about me
but yes it became sort of a byword for a
lot of this goofy stuff
that's what i'm always railing against
that's why like they play me on fox news
now yeah i mean how do you feel about
that because you went from the guy who
was
i i feel
look i'm i haven't changed
at all my politics hasn't changed
they've changed people say to me
sometimes you know have you changed no
it's it's that five years ago no one was
talking about defunding the police i
never heard that phrase five years ago
that's not me changing that's things
changing i'm reacting to it as i've
always been
you know letting three-year-olds decide
what gender they are
this wasn't something five years ago
free speech you know used to be a
left-wing thing that we were proud and
owned and now that seems to be under
attack so again i'm i think i've stayed
the same
okay as i said most of you who watch
this show who are let's say
conservatives or libertarians or
disaffected liberals whatever it is you
probably just watched the guy who was
the the thought leader of american
liberalism
at least from an entertainment
perspective or from a cultural
perspective you probably just watched
that minute long clip and agreed with
everything he said there these people
have gone bananas the left used to
defend free speech the aclu was a was a
free speech organization thought of as a
sort of lefty liberal and now what i
want to do and i'm talking to you bill
and i'm talking to your producers who
again i know watch this show when bill
says i haven't changed it's them who
have changed and he's talking about
wokeness and he's talking about the
gender stuff and he's talking about free
speech and critical race theory and all
of those things it's like you're right
you haven't changed but the liberals
have there are virtually no liberals
other than you and three or four other
people
um who seem to not understand the way
everything is shifted so if you accept
that everything has shifted but you
still
endorse and vote for people who usher
this stuff in then you're just not
making the final connection right you're
not making the final jump that would
take you to from being someone who
complains about things to someone who
actually
stops the things from happening in the
first place bill maher gave barack obama
a million dollars obama helped usher in
a lot of this woke stuff
now again this isn't this isn't really a
criticism as much as like an
encouragement that i want these people
to finally get it at the end
bill said that you know a lot of this
stuff wasn't happening until three years
ago then he said maybe five years ago i
want to show you a clip and i know many
of you have seen this and i i wrote
about this and don't burn this book this
was one of my wake-up moments i was on
the left i was still on the young turks
network i was a progressive and a bernie
supporter and i was having all of these
thoughts about what the left was what
what what was happening on the left
meaning they were calling everybody
racist and bigot and they were silencing
people and shouting speakers down to
colleges and everything else and now i
want to show you this clip from 2015
this is the famous sam harris and bill
maher versus ben affleck
on real time and when you see the sort
of hysteria from ben affleck it's like
there were signs that this woke crazy
angry thing was on its way and it was
actually happening right in your studio
bill you're saying if i criticize that
you're saying that islamophobia is not a
real thing that if you're critical of
something well it's not a real thing
when we do it right
well well no it really is i'm not
denying that that certain people are
bigoted against muslims as people that's
right and that's a problem big of you
but
the
way
about this it's gross it's racist it's
not it's but it's so it's so it's like
saying that
you're a shifty jew you're not listening
to what we are saying you guys are
saying if you want to be liberals
believe in liberal principles right
freedom of speech like um you know we're
endowed by our uh forefathers an alien
blaster all men are created no ben we
have to be able to criticize bad ideas
and of course we do no liberal doesn't
okay okay but islam but why women is the
mother load of bad ideas jesus so we
have it we have
[Applause]
like blasphemy
it is
good bill right at the end right
tolerance but not for intolerance uh
that clip which i know probably everyone
watching this has seen and it's been
seen probably 50 million times on
youtube and other platforms that was a
wake up to people all over the world i
when i started talking about that clip
and i did a breakdown of that clip of
every moment of that clip on my channel
from years ago when i had like 20 000
subscribers or something like that i was
getting email from people all over india
egypt argentina saying holy cow the
thing that i've been thinking about the
left
the perfect example of it is ben affleck
they're calling them gross and racist
the clip goes on and on you've all
you've all seen it so so there have been
warning signs that something was
happening that the good liberals were on
the defense right there's there's
bill maher there's sam harris the sort
of good non-woke liberals that were
trying to use logic and reason were
dealing with people that were not using
logic and reason say ben affleck
that anger that ben affleck had in that
over the top i'm right you're wrong
you're racist that has leaked out
everywhere into society it started
online it made its way into some of
these television shows and now it's
everywhere it's all over college
campuses and the intolerance of the left
and cancel culture all of these things
this is the end result it's what we've
got on our streets right now here is a
protest uh in texas of all places but
you know texas has a very special place
called austin this is the blue epicenter
of an otherwise sane state uh they had a
big protest against don't say gay here
in florida even though they're in texas
and you're allowed to say gay here in
florida more on that in a little bit
they had a big protest and look at some
of the
tolerant people that are just the next
extension of what ben affleck was in
that very video the tolerance it's going
to knock you out of your chair take a
look what did i do that of cechi ma'am
okay everyone this person wants
attention so please look at this person
you want the attention you got it
if anybody would be interested in
talking to me by about why this is
important to them today i would love to
speak with you that's what i'm here for
you guys are saying i'm closed minded
guys i've been here i've been asking you
guys your opinions on things yeah you're
coming up she's doing it for the views
she's doing it to get um the emotions
she had a good conversation though
what have i said today that has hurt
your guy just feeling can you stop
filming because you don't have
permission to use my [ __ ] you don't have
permission that you used to post
okay well if you guys don't want to be
filmed then you should probably walk
away from my camera right
okay the girl behind the camera there
her name is savannah hernandez she is a
young latina i don't think latinx uh
journalist and she just went out there
to ask people what is it that you think
about don't say gay now there's there's
way more video on that and people get
very very angry and all that night and
when we were discussing this clip it's
like we could show you a million clips
the tick tock clips of the gender
weirdos and all of these people are
angry and screaming and all that stuff
but you get the idea that what happened
was we went from this place of if you
just if instead of making an argument
you can just call someone racist which
is what ben affleck did on bill maher's
show
if you can get away with that then what
will happen is younger people will just
do it and repeat it and mimic it and now
we have an entire generation of people
who are growing up thinking that they're
allowed to silence people that everyone
they disagree with is a racist and a
bigot and everything else
this is a problem so now i want to back
up to what bill maher said i haven't
changed now again i think you're
probably right bill you you haven't
changed and i always wonder it's like so
what are the last things that make
someone like bill maher say he's a
liberal still and i don't mean in the
you know 1820s sense of liberalism and
i wrote a book about it so i know a
little something about it right and i
think these are lofty good ideas to hold
but so when you haven't changed so i
always think well okay so what does it
mean for someone to really say that
they're a liberal in 2022 uh and a
liberal and yet also be against all of
the woke stuff as bill described the
wokeness and the critical race theory
and the gender stuff and before free
speech what bill maher is basically
saying is he's pro-choice okay and we
can all have a debate about that and i
know most of you watching this are
pro-life now i happen to be begrudgingly
pro-choice and i think 12 weeks is the
absolute cutoff and it's just a horrible
choice to have to make and we can
discuss all of the things all around
that but i'm just putting it out there
that that is one of the things that
stops say the the good liberals from
coming around but the other one
well i guess there are two more so the
second one would be that they
do you bill still believe in big
government programs that's usually what
makes people liberal i'm nice i want to
help poor people i want to help black
people i believe in affirmative action i
believe in government handouts i
believed in subsidized housing well
there's just no evidence that any of
that stuff works okay read any thomas
soul book or watch any interview with
tom a soul or or or any economist who
has really studied
any of this stuff it creates
generational poverty it keeps people in
those things so you have the abortion
one which okay so that that's fine
that's sort of a philosophical
and or religious way of viewing things
and you just don't agree with
conservatives on that religious put air
quotes on that for bill we'll get to
that in a sec then the second one is
that you you may like i just don't
understand that part yet like do you
have a complete misunderstanding of the
welfare state is there any evidence that
it works so you want to be nice i get it
liberals want to be nice and thought of
as tolerant more than anything else but
if your policies and the people you vote
for harm the people you purport to help
we got a problem there but the last one
and i think this is really the big one
is religion okay and look i spent most
of my adult years as an atheist as a
non-believer i am not an atheist anymore
i absolutely am a believer
i wrote about that in my last book i
went on tour with jordan peterson he
really helped me move on some of this
stuff but also going through my own
spiritual awakening and by the way most
most people go through their own uh move
you know there are many people who are
believers who were once atheists uh
there's not a ton i don't think that
were believers that became atheists or
you know the you know
but not to say there are none and by the
way before i go any further there are
atheists that are good people i think
bill maher probably is a very decent
human being i've met him once or twice
actually a couple years ago i met him at
the real time after party and the first
thing i said to him i swear to god first
swear to god the first thing i said to
him was bill you got to watch out for
the left and he goes ah i got the left
and it's like oh maybe i was kind of
right on that one bill anyway i think
this last thing with with these liberals
is the atheist thing i think the belief
thing they fundamentally still believe
that conservatives are backwards
religious believers
and i think that this is a huge problem
so while of course
you can
be a non-believer and be moral and
decent my good friend michael shermer my
good friend pete bogosian of course
there are atheists like that
it cannot work as an organizing
principle societies cannot work around
without something that is bigger than
themselves and i think this is now
becoming a huge problem we now live in
what i would say is sort of a godless
society that has only ushered in more
religion
and that ushers in more bureaucrats and
crazy people who just want to control
people
so now i want to link this to a video
from jordan peterson so jordan
peterson's been talking about this for a
long time here's jordan peterson in 2018
this is four years ago
talking about the necessity of religion
in order to fight tyranny and you tell
me does it sound now it's 20 22. so four
years later do you think jordan's right
or wrong about this you tell me i do
believe that the biblical texts are
foundational
i believe it in the nietzschean sense
and you know nietzsche of course
announced famously in the 1800s 1800s
that god was dead and the typical
rationalist atheist regards that as a
triumphant triumphalist proclamation but
that wasn't that for nietzsche and
nietzsche knew perfectly well and said
immediately afterward that the
consequences of that was going to be
bloody catastrophe because everything
was going to fall and he predicted the
rise of communism for example and the
deaths of tens of millions of people in
the aftermath of the death of god
because nietzsche knew perfectly well
that when you pull the cornerstone out
from underneath a building that even
though it may stay
aloft in mid-air like a cartoon
character that's wandered off a cliff
for some period of time that it will
inevitably crumble
and that it will be replaced by
something that's perhaps far worse now
nietzsche hoped it would be
it would be replaced by man's ability to
recreate meaning spontaneously out of
his psyche for example which i think is
a doomed enterprise but he knew that in
the interval it would be replaced by
both nihilism and by communist
totalitarianism which is a hell of a
prediction because it it was done like
40 years before the events actually
unfolded there have been terrible bad
things done in the name of god and
they've been terrible bad things done in
the name of communism and and and and
atheism i don't think we can i don't
want to you don't weigh them
up you'll weigh them up and you'll say
no problem
we're living on the corpse of our
ancestors like we always have that's a
very old idea i think that the reason
that the western societies essentially
work quite well is because they act out
a judeo-christian ethic and one that's
essentially predicated it's predicated
on um utmost regard for the sovereignty
of the individual so the individual
sovereign in relationship to the state
which is a remarkable idea and one
that's fundamentally religious and it's
in its in its essence
he's so good he's just so good look he's
a friend of mine obviously and i and i
toured with the guy and i love him and
he influenced me in incredible ways but
like you could hear that stuff over and
over again i mean trust me i've now
watched that clip like 10 times
and
and it still has meaning each time and
in some ways it has more meaning each
time right so he says a couple things
there that i think you see what i'm
trying to do here that
if you remove god from the equation some
level of belief some foundational belief
what he talks about as the
judeo-christian ethos in essence the it
will be replaced by something horrible
and that is exactly what nietzsche was
warning right so the atheists sort of
think oh it'll be replaced by the human
psyche that we'll all sort of believe
that or maybe not believe isn't the word
that we'll all sort of come to this
realization about what humanity is and
will be very very evolved and everything
will be pleasant and good and equal and
all of that stuff but you're seeing the
fruits
of what
that has brought to us you're seeing the
fruits of it right now we don't know if
boys or boys or girls or girls we think
that being not racist is now being
racist we think that two plus two equals
five and all of those things so the
reason i'm connecting all of these
things is i think that this part
this part of the last liberal and i mean
this with love and concern and with the
desire to fix this genuinely
the the fear of the last liberal that
they'll be thought of as some sort of
believing
religious [ __ ] it's like bill those are
the people that are now defending your
ability
to be a free thinking atheist no one is
trying to convince bill maher to accept
christ or or be a believer i'm sure
there's some people that would like that
but who are all of the people defending
all of the societal principles that
you're laying out it's now conservatives
it's republicans and the problem is
until you're willing to make that last
move and you're so damn close man
until you're willing to make that last
move and by the way i get there's a pain
point there there's a lot of people that
that used to like me and talk to me that
won't talk to me anymore because now i'm
thought of as a mean conservative right
some of them may have been in one of
those videos i just showed you um
there's a lot of those people for sure
and you live in hollywood and you've
lived in hollywood for 30 years and
people will be very very mean
but but the question is what matters
more and if truth matters more
then then you got to make the move so i
want to show you the sort of cognitive
dissonance that that this is causing for
someone like mar and again it's i mean
it the best way man i want to help you
this is mar we showed you this clip a
couple weeks ago
talking about how florida has done it
right but he has to tell people but i
won't live in florida i won't live there
but florida has done it right while all
the blue states have done it wrong
i asked for the kova deaths by state
this is per hundred thousand people the
worst is mississippi
my home state in new jersey four
fourth worst
new york sixth worst
west virginia and massachusetts are 10
and 11. right together
could there be two states who are more
unalike right than west virginia and
massachusetts and the poster boy for
keeping [ __ ] open was florida they're
down at 17.
so new york and new jersey did worse
than florida what this is saying is
florida like state open i mean i i was
just in florida i've been there a few
times since this started half of new
york has moved there
the atmosphere is just different i'm not
moving to florida i'm not promoting
florida i'm just saying aoc just went to
florida and had a good time without a
mask
okay
i'm just saying i've been to florida the
atmosphere was just night and day from
california which was gloomy and
everything was the the andromeda strain
was out there and you went to fl
you went to florida
and i'm just saying yes there are
different factors in different states
but basically it's like they stayed open
and went on with life and they didn't do
a hell of a lot worse and maybe did
better
isn't it incredible and then the
audience is applauding his liberal
audience is applauding because good
decent liberals and while i say there's
only two or three public ones the last
flicker of sanity that exists within an
old school liberal you know i'm talking
about a 1970s democrat or a jfk democrat
of course there's some of them that
still exist they get it i mean barry
weiss is there she's one of them too and
it's like half of new york has moved
there and she says it because she knows
that florida is doing it right she knows
that desantis is fighting all the stuff
that she wants to fight she would never
publicly support desantis of course but
bill says something really interesting
there he has to qualify all of the
pro-florida stuff while he's talking
about how great it is and trust me
people i have been here for three months
i should have a day counter can we start
counting the days literally i got here
on december 17th can you count the days
for me bust out the calendar we got an
abacus i got here on december 17th
87 days did you just do that in your
head
what
you just did that in your head just like
that i'm being told i've been here for
87 days okay very impressive in the 87
days that i have been here this is the
most wonderful happy decent
good place that there is a spirit of of
joy and happiness and freedom and
liberty here and it's because of the way
these people have voted but not just
because of that it's because florida man
knew something that you california
liberals have long forgotten you you
decided to believe in nothing other than
the state you replaced god as
jordan peterson talked about what
nietzsche was saying was this is a
warning man god is dead it's a warning
and the warning is man you're gonna
you're gonna erase thousands of years of
ideas what are you gonna replace it with
communism you're gonna replace it with
collectivism and perhaps something much
worse welcome to where we are at right
now so when he qualifies what he's
saying with i'm not moving to florida
i'm not promoting florida what are you
talking about bill at this point what
are you really saying
why are you not moving to florida now if
you're going to vote for democrats you
shouldn't move to florida don't move
here please
but you're not promoting florida yes you
are everything that you said after
saying i'm not promoting florida was to
promote florida because you know it's
good you know it's happy bill maher i
don't know if this is public but no it
must be public you just taped your new
hbo special last week where uh florida
yeah that's right that's right two
nights in uh florida
why not l.a
why not l.a so you see what i'm trying
to do here i'm trying to paint a picture
so let's go a little bit further with
this painting uh the big thing of course
all of last week is this don't say gay
bill
here in florida and of course the word
gay is not in the bill you are allowed
to say gay gay gay you can say gay you
can dance down the hallway in a school
singing gay you can do whatever gay
stuff you want to do nobody really cares
they just don't want you doing it in
their face which i think is a very fair
premise
the bill is called hb 1557. here's just
a couple of the bullet points that we've
shown you a few times so in essence what
this is about is they don't want
kindergartners
to third graders to be taught about
gender identity or sexuality if a
kindergartner or third grader walks in
and says i have two mommies or two
daddies you are not going to be kicked
out of school they are not going to not
allow your parents to come to the play
where you're the lower incisor in the
tooth play or anything else this is that
they don't want these discussions
happening
in school let's just pull up the bullet
points one more time real quick uh the
other things that are the little more
specifics and i know i've gone through
this but it's worth repeating just real
quick we'll knock out the five of them
they want to notify parents of changes
to health or well-being of course you
would want that they don't want to
encourage withholding of info from
parents why should a state
government school be allowed to do that
allow parents to access child student
records of course that makes sense let
parents refuse school health care
services sure and get parental
permission for health screening these
are all obvious things that we all know
we all know them to be true and there is
no first grader out there that thinks
that they're closeted or the wrong
gender that should be able to talk to a
parent a a
a teacher and then hide that from the
parent we all just know this this is the
sheer lunacy that they do with
everything but so desantis is signing
the bill this is happening people are
going bananas every mainstream thing
everywhere don't say gay well now disney
disney which is the woke corporation
that does plenty of business in china
and has no problem uh with their
concentration camps for the uyghur
muslims and has no problem with how they
you know do their sneakers with nike in
in the factories and all that stuff but
disney's really really good they're
really really good as they propagandize
all of their woke movies to everybody
and they've ruined star wars and
everything else
um
disney is uh had a sit-down the ceo of
disney had a sit-down with ron desantis
and basically he was trying to say to
him hey you better do what we want and
you better not sign this bill and
desantis was like no
he was he just flat out said it no i'm
signing the freaking bill we showed you
the video on friday where desantis gave
a speech afterwards saying we are just
knocking about awoke corporations and i
am the
chief executive of the state of florida
i am i am
the guy that is supposed to do what's
right for the people of florida not
what's what's what's apparently right
for a giant corporation disney here's a
tweet from gavin newsom he is the evil
monster who is running california the
state that i fled he now wants disney to
come back to california disney the door
is open to bringing those jobs back to
california the state that actually
represents the values of your workers
now first off of course because i
mentioned california i've got to put
some money into the california fund and
somebody in the locals community i will
pay cash money to to leave california
and move to florida at the end of the
year now gavin newsom who he's just an
evil psychopath
um he closed disney for most of 2020 and
2021 uh put a whole bunch of disney
workers uh out on the streets close up
the schools you know all the stuff so he
ruined california disney but now he's
saying we'll take you back now he may
close them again because coveted two is
coming obviously like this this was just
the test run there's obviously going to
be a covet too um
so gavin newsom you're just evil and by
the way disney's not going to leave
florida what disney then did do which is
this is so hilarious it's so it's so
wonderful so i saw all these blue check
people saying how could disney give
money to the evil republicans and how
could they give money to these evil
florida legislators voting for this so
you know what disney decided to do
they're not giving any money to anyone
in florida anymore that's right and it's
like good
zippity-doo-dah i believe that's a
phrase from a disney movie
zippity-doo-dah zippity-a my oh my what
a wonderful day yeah you did it disney
thank you so and then they they
criticize uh desantis for this like oh
see he's not even gonna take disney's
money anymore oh so our politicians are
not gonna be bought off by giant
corporations this is good
so disney's money will not go to
democrats or republicans in this state
anymore spectacular
wonderful hallelujah and by the way ron
desantis is right because parents
as he said on friday parents
don't want their kids indoctrinated with
this stuff and parents you're not going
to believe this bring their kids to
disney so i think he's on the winning
end of this stick
well desantis also isn't taking it that
he put out this spectacular video on
twitter a couple days ago this is just
great just firing back on
uh the media and how they lie and lie
and lie and lie about everything but in
this case
don't say
gay
ron desantis has taken a stand and said
no you can't acknowledge that gay exists
at all is discriminatory uh a form of
bullying or a so-called don't say gay
bill don't say gay bill don't say gay
bill
does it say that in the bill does it say
that in the bill i'm asking him i'm
asking you to tell me what's in the bill
because you are pushing false narratives
it's why people don't trust people like
you because you peddle false narratives
disney ceo bob chapek weighing in on
that florida bill the company has been
opposed to the bill from the outset the
chance that i am going to
back down from my commitment to students
and back down from my commitment to
parents rights
simply because of fraudulent media
narratives or pressure from woke
corporations the chances of that are
zero
how do they possibly explain
lining their pockets with their
relationship from the communist party of
china
because that's what they do and they
make a fortune
they don't say a word our policy is
going to be based on the best interest
of florida citizens not on the musing of
he could have just ended it there by
saying our policy is going to be based
that could have been the end of it you
know based this is you can either be
woke and if you're not woke and you're
really fighting it the right way as i
try to do here you are based that's what
the kids say michael is that what the
kids say i always ask michael for what
he got any other phrases that the kids
are saying these days
base is good all right give me another
one tomorrow i want to know what the
kids are saying um that's how you fight
back that's how you fight back you don't
take it lying down and the point of
today's show in case
i was not clear is that bill maher
last liberals you got to get there now
now we're there now we're there
we are we are
past the point of debate
bill you're right about a lot of stuff
we have a couple disagreements does not
matter but until you can promote florida
without feeling guilty about it until
you can say i will support support glenn
younkin
because he got critical race theory out
of schools in virginia and i'm always
railing against critical race theory
until you can say that there are no
democrats
that support any of the ideas that i
believe in any of my liberal beliefs who
believes more in your liberal beliefs
your true liberal beliefs at this point
bill maher
is it the democrats or the republicans
and that does not mean the republicans
are great the republicans are mostly a
bunch of squishy nothing do nothing
backwards mitch mcconnell we can find 14
billion dollars for ukraine but we can't
find any money for our own people
monsters okay but
they're better than the other thing and
until if you really care about critical
race theory and you really want to stop
wokeness and you really want states to
open up and you really don't want
mandates and all of those things
then you got to get to the end of the
road man so this is a this is a welcome
i'll i'll make a basket for you
of stuff we'll get i'll get weed i know
you like weed what else do you think
bill maher likes he likes weed
we'll get him another pair he wears
glasses now he wears the sn smart
newsman glasses we get him some extra
glasses we'll get you weed and glasses
man
all right is that enough whatever else
you want a couple comments from the
reubenreport.locals.com community uh
carpenter says mike pence just needs to
identify as a black woman don't we all
carpenter don't we all
jennifer's says the view sounds more
like the screech yeah it's unbearable
and i did connor did you put the warning
up before we showed the view clip today
you didn't put the warning okay that's
connor's fault uh and he will be docked
pay uh but we should put the warning
that what you're gonna see when i throw
to the view is is
moronic idiotic
muted if you have to type stuff so
bad move connor sorry
abe says they should just rename this
administration the dog that ate my
homework administration
nothing is their fault miraculously yeah
it's really incredible i mean what
they're doing right now with with this
inflation stuff and obviously we're
going to
talk more about it this week not only
inflation but the
the gas prices which are all connected
supply chain stuff it's like this is all
russia's fault as if we have no autonomy
over our own economy as if our policies
that as if the policies that these
people pass and the money
that they print i mean the crazy amount
of money that we have printed so that
you can get a check for 150 while we
give money to everybody across the world
and we have no money we are a debtor
nation thank god we've got nukes because
one day they might call in the uh the
debt right and then uh this is it's it's
a mafia game like at the end of the year
you didn't pay me back uh you know we're
gonna take you out for a ride to jersey
okay but if you've got a bigger gun than
that guy then you're gonna be okay so
we've got a lot of weapons and that's
why this thing can't end well ah didn't
want to end the show that way with the
nuclear war thing uh here's a meme
monday situation we've got from the
reuben report community we do this every
monday we got the meme do we have the
meme oh we don't have the meme uh that's
all right you can go to reubenreport.com
reubenreport.locals.com to see today's
meme monday image and it's all about the
putin and the price hike and the npcs
and all that good stuff
i feel very good about the show today
bill
bill's producers who are watching i'm
trying i'm trying last liberals enough
of this it's just it's just enough you
had a good run enough enough and uh if i
wasn't clear in the way i thought and
laid this all out today you're gonna
really dig my book because i think it's
the is the final nail in the coffin of
what you're doing you can pre-order it
right now don't burn this country at
daverubin.com
book
and uh you can play along during the
shows with our live chat over at
reubenreport.locals.com my full
interview with nikki haley is up on
youtube and rumble and locals right now
and uh we will continue this
tomorrow i'm having a little
get-together tonight with some of the
right-wing maniacs in florida maybe i'll
take some video of that as we're
wrestling alligators and doing stuff all
right see ya bye